Hmm
Today I am google developer-rated Suzuki
Today, we are having a visit to Mr. Keisuke Ohashi of humanity of gd google apps api
I hope to talk to you in various ways.
Even though I'm holding a chan, I'm introducing myself.
Google Apps Script is
Of course after 3 years and 4 years
And because I touch the app in my company there
Write a script to streamline your company's various tasks, and so on
Oh
8 I like that up split
What to send updates to Japanese people as quickly as one second
You're doing it on Google+
I think that it was the year that was started three years ago, but it is the way to start three years ago
I wonder if
The same google developer Expert Mr. Tatsumi
I started study session of study session aps script just around that time and I was already full for the second time of the fifth time
I have been participating since the second time, so it's amazing there
I thought it could be used
Did you continue doing it after that?
When I thought that it was usable, I tried to make something first when I stab it
Being
Overwintering is what I try to make in company management
This company emails state law to all employees once a week, so the company size is around 200 people
Because
It's very difficult to figure out who's out and who's out
So I have 20 people in my class that I have nobody out who is out
About
I would like to check very much who is out there on the scale
I went to work every week, but it
At first it was very exciting because it was excel at first.
Turn it all into a spreadsheet
Automatically collect emails using google apis tape
It is the first time that you write a script that automatically checks
From then on, it is said that the person is a lot of continuous work and the public is a little depravity of that child
It is almost already said that it is written by that up script
Well
If you do it in your own hands 10 minutes or more like 5 minutes
But I think it would be awful stress to do it every week
Maybe a lot of people
I do not feel even stress
It's a tiny job, something like routine work
If it is true if it can be zero
In fact, you can make time to continue with other work
I'm still thinking that there is a bus flip attraction so much over there
Is
Speaking of grandma, maybe the best in that community
I think that one who is in line numbering immediately but
It's pretty much right now that the benefits are so many various engines and sweet bites t
I think that it will be posted or some question will come but what
Hano
Do you think that it is an app or something that can be used effectively effectively?
Yes yes
The part where Higashi Aso can be used seems like I entered earlier
Really do 5 minutes or 1 minute every day
I have to do it 100 times a day for 101 days
I really do not feel as stress in myself
It's kind of annoying, I think it's hard to do today
Even small repetitive tasks are getting worse and worse
That kind of thing is most suitable for you
I think it is a part that is facing
For example, though it is in the community's name list in the community
Well, I have never actually attended a study session at that event
I haven't posted a question yet, I saw some advice for those people
Do you
First of all, if it is Google Plus 8
hashtag
In sharp
Gasman gaas ah
I would like to go if you can post it to me
Ah
Gd's niece or something
I'm looking to Meiji, so it's overwintering
Oh dear
Suddenly send e-mail to two people or
I think it's a great pain to ask questions in the community, but when you're first
I'm thrilled
It seems like you can't cheat with a hash and you can't do this.
I thought it would be good if I could start by saying something from the beginning
How much it lowers the cost of dedicating the hard of that post so much
That's right, so we can catch up with such things as much as possible
I'm trying to look at it, so if it's cut off that's all connected from that place
I think there are probably many things that I can not solve, but I bother together
That's all right
There's no way I can't do it like I'm troubled with that together
It's not
It's the best to connect and talk, it's great if it's your first day
It may be possible to shorten the time to make it
Use only or
If it comes out that a bullet comes out and it should be said that I will throw it to of unity
I think
Case blue is really cool in the real car
I think that the correspondence is properly and carefully
I think that you have answered the earthquake-resistant diagnosis to Kita Petit and was there
Good place
Please do something with fill up script
Is it difficult in the body or something that can be done or the connection between a real side man and a person there is one
If you say that it is the connection of the people of another one, I try to sample script as possible
I like to write
Be sure to see if you ask questions so that you can see the other party
I am conscious and I do not want to automate there in my alma mater
It is overwintering what we had everyone give out by all means
Well make a sample app within the range you can answer
Well, if you can't do that, you'll get something that bothers you together
To say that the trouble is solved
I would like to do something in shape, not gas
Also I think that you can do something like automatic response in the work of the second 2 with gas
In the end, I am a person who studied gas from now
If you just get a message from someone interested in just watching this broadcast
I'm glad but how
It is me or some other people
That kind of event that gd Nao-san or something is doing
I think it's one thing to have you come first
Even if you just follow us on the gd site, that's almost daily
As we are talking about Google Up Pretty Cure, look at such information
First of all I know that I can do something like this that I'm interested in
I think that it is the first step 1 of getting
If you are interested and have time, of course you will come to the event
Naa like writing a bowler
The article called Grappl script which starts in 5 minutes is suitable, so please have a look
Do it
Something deep now
I think if you can put it in the direction of efficiency of your own work of grappl script
Well then that's why everyone said that would start in that 5 minutes
I'm on a blog site like that in the Wing Perth community
I think I can see it by all means because I am writing
Today, I would like to hear Mr. Keisuke Hashi, who is gd of Google Apps, listen to various stories
I have
Thank you very much thank you very much